I'm at my desk and the desk is a surface
okay and I start putting pages down on
the desk of tiling them on the desk and
then I run out of room I have exhausted
the two dimensions of the surface of my
desk we have ways of accommodating this
problem and so we have page organizers
that go upwards so now and I don't have
any more surface area of the desk I can
enter a third dimension and put pages
there if you are an ant embedded in this
two-dimensional world of the surface of
my desk and you fill up the desk with
these sheets of paper the ant will say
there is no more room and I say yes
there is watch me and I take a piece of
paper off the desk put it in the page
organizer and according to the ant
that's embedded in the two dimensions
that page disappeared it disappeared
into a dimension that ant does not have
access to what a brilliant invention
this is you can put practically an
unlimited number of pages but far more
pages above the desk then on the desk so
access to a third dimension is an
extraordinarily useful storage device
watch what happens next I now have my
three-dimensional room and I'm filling
it with boxes now I've run out of space
to put the boxes
but now an alien four-dimensional alien
looks at us and says I got this just
move it into the fourth dimension what
are you talking about and the alien
comes in reaches in takes one of the
boxes and then the Box disappears
disappears it went into a fourth
dimension so imagine a new storage
system we just go to Home Depot and buy
a door and that door is your portal to a
fourth dimension you open the door put
your boxes close the door you look on
the other side of the door there's
nothing there so this is what's going on
when you have access to higher
dimensions now there are things that
happen in quantum physics that kind of
defy our sensibilities like particles
pop in and out of existence they don't
they defy any rational attempt to
understand it the particles can be
entangled with one another a particle
can be here and there's a barrier and it
can spontaneously show up on the other
side of the barrier at faster than the
speed of light all of this is just
mysterious so who is to say that some of
the mysterious things we are describing
accurately but don't otherwise make
sense makes sense in a higher dimension
and these are just the manifestations of
higher dimensional phenomena in our
world and that's an aspect of what these
higher dimensional physicists are trying
to establish
[Music]
you